[Music]  after months of speculation  kendall Jenner and ASAP rocky  relationship rumors are true oh my god  just be cool a source close to the 21  year old reality star tells ET Kendall  is in fact dating the 28 year old rapper  but don't expect the pair to say so in  the near future our source adds quote I  don't think you will be seeing them make  a public announcement anytime soon but  the insider says quote Kindle is happy I  like to keep my private life pretty  private  candolyn ASAP were recently spotted  packing on the PDA at the 2017 Met Gala  getting cozy in a group bathroom selfie  and here's the fashion killer rapper  copping a feel of the models butt